debilitating pain has dominated francis
wakefield's life for years after a car
accident
but now he's in even more agony because
of complications following eye surgery
i don't know which is worse
the headaches
are the physical pains
i had
cataracts done
a few years back
since having the cataract surgery and
the implants put in the eye
i've suffered with triple vision
and for over the last three years and is
over the last three years
i'm still waiting to go back to have it
corrected
while francis waits his distorted vision
is causing daily migraines it's
excruciating
and there are far too many others with
stories like his
the latest nhs figures showed almost six
and a half million people are waiting
for treatment that's a record and a
massive increase on 4.4 million people
before the pandemic
so to tackle the backlog patients
waiting two years or more can now go to
another part of the country where they
can be treated sooner the cost of travel
and accommodation will be covered but
for francis a long car journey could
mean unbearable pain that would be a
nightmare for me
and i wouldn't be able to just go
straight there and come straight back
i'm sorry
but in the medical community there is
cautious optimism
i think we shouldn't be um too concerned
about patients being offered care out of
area as long as that there's provisions
for people say for example who go for
knees and hop hip operations to have
follow-up care locally if needed the nhs
says it's on track to treat all those
waiting two years or more by the end of
next month but they'll need patients
willing and able to travel potentially
hundreds of miles away from home for
this plan to work becky cottrell sky
news lancashire